plus de 38% des suffrages exprimés pour
le duo et long courtois Jean-Michel
fourgousse Anne capillaud la liste de
l'Union de la Droite réalisée un bon
premier tour sur le canton de Trappes
même si l'abstention est à prendre en
compte 63% sur l'ensemble du secteur et
jusqu'à 70 % sur la ville de tram quel
est votre sentiment mais écoutez d'abord
bien sûr la prudence parce que
il faut pas pris victoire voilà et puis
surtout non moi j'ai la bonne nouvelle
de cela on sent bien entendu qu'il y a
une vague bleue dans ma ville je le sens
bien très fortement bon et puis
globalement même sur le quand on s'en
vient une différence voilà qui est
claire le maire d'Élancourt et son
adjointe porté par leur ville ou un
électeur sur deux leur font confiance
elle à la gauche était divisée dans ce
scrutin front de Gaucher Europe Écologie
Les Verts préférant s'allier laissant
seul le Parti socialiste elle est
socialiste pourtant en sortant sur ce
canton et qui arrive second avec
29,88%. maintenant il y a une semaine
pour mobiliser les abstentionnistes et
s'assurer que les reports de gauche
fonctionnent bien puisqu'il y a
effectivement des réserves de voies à
gauche importantes donc on va les
chercher à la fois sur la deuxième liste
et puis à la fois sur les
abstentionnistes la liste Front de
Gauche Europe Écologie Les Verts qui
totalise 11,07% et qui appelle
aujourd'hui abattre la droite dans un
communiqué diffusé par son candidat Luc
miserait quant au Front national porté
par le binôme Maribo Nicolas Bauer il
arrive second sur la ville même de
Trappes avec 797 voix mais seulement 3e
dans le canton avec 16,21% je voudrais
quand même dire un mot sur sur la
commune d'Élancourt on a quand même
doublé
notre score par rapport aux élections
municipales pour laquelle j'avais été
candidat et élu conseiller municipal
donc je pense que cet ancrage se fait de
manière fasse s'impose même comme a dit
tout à l'heure votre confrère par lapsus
plutôt rigolo en dire le Front national
s'impose dans le canton
je crois que tout ce travail que j'ai
mené depuis un an au conseil municipal a
porté ses fruits et bien évidemment je
continuerai ce travail de terrain aucune
consigne de vote pour le Front national
le canton de Trappes a été remanié
depuis le dernier scrutin puisque
dorénavant Élancourt et la verrière ils
sont rattachés